I've been talking to my sources
following the New York Comic-Con about
Star Trek and we've got a very
interesting rumor to tell you about
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so obviously you've probably if you are
a Trekkie I heard the rumored that Alex
kurtzman let's slip that they've been
talking about Janeway returning to a
live-action Star Trek series and
Jonathan Frakes letting slip that these
might not be the last voyages for at
least some of the crew of the Enterprise
but what does all this mean because
we've had lots of rumors about Star Trek
series coming up like section 31 that
don't seem to be going anywhere and
there's going to be a hole left behind
by Picard that we assume a new series
will step in and fill but what series
will that be well as I say it doesn't
look like section 31 is happening from
what I'm being told Michelle yeoh has
signed up to a couple of other different
projects now and even though that's
project and that series would have been
amazing it doesn't look like it's
happening
there were a couple of other Star Trek
ideas as well but it looks like kurtzman
has decided to go in a different
direction
he has seen the popularity of lower
decks he has seen the popularity of
Prodigy and characters like Janeway
returning and he wants to do something
live action in that time frame now
Picard has not been a massive success
but we can even see from Picard Series 3
from what we've seen so far at least
that Alex kurtzman is already going this
direction of bringing back all the
characters and setting a story within a
federation that we know and love within
the time frame of a few years after the
Next Generation so what I'm being told
by my sources is that we are going to
get a TV show that is based around the
Next Generation time frame that will
follow on immediately after Picard
series three it will be within the
universe that's roughly been set up by
Picard but I'm also being told that big
sections of a particular Picard series
one are going to be completely ignored
there's a whole Android wall and all
that sort of thing that I'm being told
did not go down well with fans
because it didn't make sense it was a
bit [ __ ]
um and will be generally ignored in this
new series but what will the new series
be I hear you cry that a series is
currently in development that will
follow the USS Titan and we'll have
seven of nine
generally one of the most popular
characters to have returned to the
picardo series as Captain make it so
make it so now I would prefer we saw the
next generation of the Next Generation
get the Enterprise F The Odyssey car
Starship that we're going to see we know
we've seen it in the trailer
we're going to see in Picard series
three and follow the adventures of that
ship but it doesn't look like that's
what's going to happen I did wonder
whether they might go and basically
build a series based on the Stargazer
but it's just like that that's gonna
happen either it seems to be that it's
going to be the USS Titan
but it's going to be an episodic series
that again kurtzman has learned his
lesson and the popularity of strange new
worlds has taught them a valuable lesson
and the series will be based more on
that sort of style but in the modern
time frame I say modern the time frame
we're used to as in following from the
Next Generation
so over the next couple of years what
Star Trek going to look like it looks
like Star Trek is going to be strange
new rules that is moving towards
remaking the the original series as far
as I can tell it's going to be Prodigy
it is going to be lower decks and it is
going to be the last couple of series of
discovery which is obviously way in the
future and we're going to have a Next
Generation time frame series with seven
of nine as Captain aboard the USS Titan
a ship then I'm sorry
I really don't like
[Music]
so that's a more problem I actually I
saw this in the original teaser trailer
for Picard Series 3 and I really didn't
like it it's a sorcer section and the
whole front of the lower Hall
supposed to be a mix between modern and
Originals because this is obviously
vessel is supposed to be a constellation
class a new constellation class
doesn't work it just doesn't it's not
it's just ugly
um I actually then start to see it
traveling at warp I thought actually it
did look pretty cool at War but it's one
of those ships that just looks better
moving I don't know why
um but then I saw it in lots of other
angles and some angles I like some
angles I hate
there's been a lot of stuff on social
media and actually the guide that
designed the the ship has had a lot of
[ __ ] on Twitter which I don't make that
makes no sense he's creating a design
you don't like
it's not a personal attack don't give
him crap for it you know it's just like
ah don't get that but it's not a ship I
like moving on
I do actually though love the idea of a
new series with um seven of nine
[Music]
she is one of the more interesting
characters within at this time frame she
has been absolutely brilliant in Picard
Series 2 in particular and if it is true
and this is the direction their tank and
Star Trek this is a series I will most
definitely give serious attention to and
we'll have to re-subscribe to Paramount
plus to watch which is annoying but I'm
gonna have to resubscribe when strange
new world comes out anyway so now that's
the way to deal with streaming services
by the way pay for them for a month
cancel them leave it a couple of months
pay for it for a month again
binge watch everything that we cancel it
that way you only have to have one maybe
two streaming services at a time and you
get to save some money but guys what do
you think about this rumor that that's
the way they're taking Star Trek in the
next couple of years
is it something you'd want to see or is
it just yeah more kurtzman rubbish get
in the comments and tell me exactly what
you think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you want to become a fully fled side
tracker and you enjoy the content hit
the join button as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]